down in georgia gubernatorial candidate
stacey abrams is in more hot water
tonight we are now learning
that marjorie casey
the foundation she worked on board
members that stacey abrams serves on
increased their anti-police funding
shortly after she joined the board and
with her approval that's despite her
campaign saying she disagrees with the
foundation on these issues here with
reaction is republican senate candidate
in georgia herschel walker who had a
huge win in his primary herschel uh
great to have you back i'm supporting
your candidacy uh you're a friend and i
think you'll be a great senator from the
great state of georgia uh where do
things stand there tonight
well things stand well right now you
know where the big races on and you're
100 correct it's going to be a tough
race you with stacey abrams you see what
she's done in georgia she said that she
don't even think this is one of the
worst states to live and the guy i'm
running against uh maybe he believed the
same thing because he did say and she
said that they're running on the same
ticket meaning that they believe in the
same thing that means that they like
these high gas prices well i don't they
like these
milk and eggs to be as how they are well
i don't and we got to get this crime
back together you talked about it most
all these cities that's ran by democrats
they have crime that has gone outrageous
and even right now you look at the
border what is going on with the border
they were talking about earlier a couple
of months ago now they don't seem to be
caring about right now they've gotten on
to something else and we got to get
these things solved we got to get people
in office that want to solve problems
rather than get a sound bite record gas
prices record high inflation uh we now
have the the largest caravan heading our
way uh since these caravans started uh
right now that's happening uh the
disaster in afghanistan uh every single
day people paying more for every item
they buy every time you fill up your gas
tank americans are feeling the pain
question is okay let's assume the
republicans can take the house let's
assume people like you can win and bud
can win and we can pick off a state like
new hampshire nevada with that laxalt
and arizona assuming all that's true j.d
vance amendment oz
if that happens what will republicans be
able to do with joe biden as a president
well one thing we've got to do is get
this country back together and try to
get the gas of price down you know
that's one of the things i think most
people when i'm going around talking to
georgians they're worried about they're
worried about the gas price you know and
people forget about when we lose our
energy that's a national security
problem and no one seems to be talking
about that we got to get these gas
prices down we got to continue to
support our men and women in blue we got
to get this country back together and
hide in the world could we forget about
baby formula you know they were talking
about they forgot about baby formula
well we got to get those things back
together so when i get into office and i
want everyone to go to teamhurster.com
put herschel walk in that seat because
the big race is on now all right and
herschel uh we're supporting your
candidacy uh watching it closely thanks
for being with us hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else